un brasier meurtrier que les pompiers
ont mis une douzaine d'heures à
maîtriser en attendant l’enquête
publique de la coronaire des documents
montrent que le bâtiment accumulé les
non-conformités pendant plus de 10 ans
en 2009 quelques mois après avoir fait
l'acquisition de l'immeuble patrimonial
le propriétaire reçoit un premier
rapport du service incendie
l'inspectrice note des problèmes de
séparation coupe-feu un couloir qui se
termine en un pass ou le fait que des
locataires n'ont plus accès à l'escalier
de secours un an plus tard toujours
concernant l'escalier de secours des
soudures ont été faites ce qui empêche
l'escalier de descendre au niveau du sol
en 2011 le propriétaire n'avait toujours
pas prouvé qu'il avait vérifié les
systèmes d'alarme et de détection
incendies mais on note aussi à ce moment
là que le service incendie veut faire
annuler des poursuites concernant les
moyens d'évacuation des manquements
seront corrigés mais d'autres s'ajoutent
en 2012 des panneaux sortis lumineux
brisés à plusieurs endroits des
avertisseurs de fumée défectueux une
issue non conforme ou encore une
séparation coupe-feu qui ne se prolonge
pas jusqu'au plafond et la liste
s'allonge encore en 2018 le service
incendie n'a pas pu constater la
présence d'avertisseurs sonore dans les
logements et quand il y en a les
inspecteurs notent en 2020 que le niveau
acoustique de certains d'entre eux n'est
pas suffisant
le dernier rapport disponible date du 23
janvier 2021 pour absence de
vérification des réseaux d'avertisseurs
c'était un peu plus de deux ans avant
l'incendie la Ville de Montréal n'a pas
souhaité commenter ses documents ici
Mathieu Prost Radio-Canada Montréal